here's a guy was in the military right
here what up Brendan got a debate club
for you guys today robbing banks who
would you rather have beef with OJ
Simpson or that [ __ ] care of by askin
remember they both got away with murder
allegedly on Carol Baskin she would
rather have beef with gang gang lick
butts
that's tough one I'm less worried about
Carol Baskin I'm not trying to touch
those Tigers I'm never gonna go to the
zoo
Oh Jase everywhere dog oh he's out here
he's in Vegas yeah Florida oh yeah
he's giving you coming comments on
[ __ ] Instagram and Twitter
he gave me a eulogy somewhere at
somebody's funeral dearly eulogy are you
you you long everywhere Carol just well
Carol's low key right now because also
Carol screwed everybody Carol is a
businesswoman though now I will say that
you know she took over the yeah the the
[ __ ] zoo and exotics yeah she took
over the zoo but apparently PETA called
because the lines are covered in maggots
and flies oh my oh my it's getting risky
man Wow
I don't know bro I look if I had two
arrows brah I'd shoot him at both them
[ __ ] honestly dawg yeah I mean OJ's
turning like a character almost of
himself but he's out there playing golf
yeah you know I killed a woman or knew
somebody that did he definitely did it
yeah got somebody to do that convicted
in civil court I didn't realize he still
gets money from home no they garnish his
wages it all goes to the Nicole Brown
family oh wow I don't know how I don't
know how he's living there doing it
somehow to know somehow hello
the world hello Twitter world yeah well
[Laughter]
[Music]